COVID-19 THAT IS BOTH
UNFATHOMABLE AND FRANKLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
THE U.S. DEATH TOLL FROM THIS
PANDEMIC JUST ROSE ABOVE
675,000.
THAT'S HIGHER THAN THE DEATH
TOLL FROM THE 1918 FLU PANDEMIC
MORE THAN 100 YEARS AGO.
THE YOUNGEST AMERICANS ARE
INCREASINGLY AT RISK IN THIS
CRISIS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES, AND TONIGHT THEY MAY BE
CLOSER TO BEING ELIGIBLE FOR
VACCINATIONS.
PFIZER SAYS ITS VACCINE IS SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE FOR CHILDREN AGES
5 TO 11.
IN A SMALLER DOSE, A LOWER DOSE
THAN ADULTS GET.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS AND
MUCH MORE WITH DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, THE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND THE
CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
DR. FAUCI, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
AS WE PASS THIS VERY GRIM
MILESTONE, WE'RE STILL LOSING AN
AVERAGE OF NEARLY 2,000
AMERICANS TO THIS VIRUS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
HOW HIGH DO YOU FEAR, DR. FAUCI,
THE DEATH TOLL COULD GO, AND
WHAT SHOULD WE BE BRACING FOR?
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO BE
PREDICT HOW HIGH IT CAN GO.
I CAN ONLY SAY WHAT WE DO KNOW
IS THAT WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES.
WE HAVE THE VACCINES TO STOP
THAT AND TURN THAT AROUND, WOLF.
AS I'VE TOLD YOU MANY TIMES, WE
NOW, TODAY, HAVE APPROXIMATELY
70 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE VACCINATED WHO
HAVE NOT YET GOTTEN VACCINATED.
IF WE GET OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF THOSE PEOPLE VACCINATED, WE
WILL NOT SEE THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED.
2,000 DEATHS PER DAY IS
ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THAT WAY, WAY
DOWN, AND WE CAN DO THAT BY
VACCINATING THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WHEN
THEY GET INFECTED HAVE A HIGH
DEGREE OF LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING
ON TO A SEVERE DISEASE.
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE DRIVING THIS PANDEMIC.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THESE PEOPLE
VACCINATED, WOLF.
>> WE CERTAINLY DO.
THREE MONTHS AGO ABOUT 200
AMERICANS WERE DYING EVERY DAY
FROM COVID-19 AND NOW IT'S 2000.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY UNACCEPTABLE.
AS YOU KNOW, DR. FAUCI, PFIZER
SAYS A LOW DOSE CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE IS SAFE FOR CHILDREN
AGES 5 TO 11 YEARS OLD.
HOW BIG OF A GAME-CHANGER WOULD
THIS BE, AND HOW QUICKLY COULD
CHILDREN IN THIS AGE GROUP START
ACTUALLY GETTING VACCINATED?
>> WELL, THE DATA IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED TO THE FDA FOR
APPLICATION OF AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION.
WHEN THE FDA LOOKS AT, THAT I'M
SURE THEY WILL WORK VERY QUICKLY
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION AS
OFFICIALLY TO ITS SAFETY AND ITS
EFFICACY SO I WOULD IMAGINE
WE'RE TALKING IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS, POSSIBLY BY THE END OF
THE MONTH, BEGINNING OF NEXT
MONTH BECAUSE I NOTE FDA REALLY
WANTS TO DO IT CORRECTLY, BUT
THEY WANT TO DO IT QUICKLY.
WITH REGARD TO THE IMPACT, WE
ALREADY KNOW, WOLF, THAT PARENTS
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
CHILDREN OF THAT AGE GROUP,
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE GOING
INTO THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AGE
RANGE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
THOROUGHLY PROTECT THEM.
BEFORE WE WERE PROTECTING THEM
BY SURROUNDING THEM WITH PEOPLE
WHO WERE VACCINATED.
NOW THEY THEMSELVES, IF THE FDA
GIVES THE APPROVAL, CAN BE
PROTECTED BY THEIR OWN
VACCINATION.
>> AS YOU KNOW, PFIZER MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT DID NOT
PUBLICLY RELEASE THE DATA BEHIND
IT.
IS THERE ANY REASON, DR. FAUCI,
TO BE SKEPTICAL OF THESE
FINDINGS?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL, WOLF.
I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT IF THEY
FEEL THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
PRESENT THAT TO THE FDA FOR AN
EUA APPROVAL, I DOUBT VERY
SERIOUSLY THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT IN THAT
DATA.
>> WHY IS IT THAT A 12-YEAR-OLD
CHILD IS GETTING VACCINATED WITH
A FULL DOSE THAT IS THREE TIMES
THE SIZE OF THE DOSE THAT WILL
BE GIVEN TO AN 11-YEAR-OLD?
IS THE DISTINCTION BASED ON
DEVELOPMENT, WEIGHT, SOMETHING
ELSE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION OUT THERE FOR A LOT OF
PARENTS WHO HAVE CHILDREN IN
THAT SPECIFIC AGE RANGE?
>> THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE, WOLF,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A CUTOFF
POINT AND DO SOMETHING THAT'S
LOGISTICALLY FEASIBLE.
IF YOU START TALKING ABOUT
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT DOSES DOWN BY
WEIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE, A MICROGRAM
PER KILOGRAM REGIMEN, THAT'S
GOING TO BE CONFUSING.
IT'S GOING TO BE MORE CONFUSING
THAN WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW, SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CUTOFF POINT.
THE DECISION WAS CHILDREN FROM
11 DOWN INSTEAD OF GETTING THE
30 MICROGRAM DOSE WILL GET A 10
MICROGRAM DOSE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH THAT AND PARENTS
SHOULD NOT BE CONFUSED OR
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
>> LAST FRIDAY FDA VACCINE
ADVISERS RECOMMENDED BOOSTERS
FOR AMERICANS 56 AND OLDER AND
THOSE WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK.
YOU PREDICTED THAT THE FDA
DECISION ABOUT BOOSTERS WILL
LIKELY BE REVISED AS MORE DATA
BECOMES AVAILABLE.
WHAT KIND OF DATA WOULD CHANGE
THE CALCULUS HERE, DR. FAUCI?
>> WELL, THERE WILL BE DATA
COMING IN FROM OUR OWN COHORTS
THROUGH THE CDC AND THE OTHERS
ARE FOLLOWING AS WELL AS FROM
THE ISRAELIS WHO WILL
CONTINUALLY HAVE DATA FOR US,
BOTH FOR THE WANING OF
PROTECTION, PARTICULARLY AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE IN YOUNGER GROUPS
MANY WOULD TRIGGER THE FDA TO
LOOK AT THAT AND SEE IF THEY
WANT TO EXPAND THE
RECOMMENDATION TO GO MUCH
YOUNGER THAN 65.
ALL OF THAT DATA IS GOING TO BE
COMING IN IN REAL TIME ON A
WEEKLY BASIS.
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT, WOLF, WHEN
YOU GET DOWN TO THE YOUNGER
GROUP, PARTICULARLY A YOUNG MEN
WHERE THE POTENTIAL FOR THE RARE
ADVERSE EFFECT OF MIA CARDITIS
EXISTS, THAT WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO GET GOOD SAFETY
DATA IN PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
YOUNG MEN AND AS WE DO IT'S
LIKELY WE'LL GO OVER THE COMING
WEEKS AND SEE MORE AND MORE OF
AN EXPANSION OF THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE BOOSTERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
>> THE BOOSTER SHOT
CONVERSATION, AS YOU KNOW, HAS
BEEN CENTERED STRICTLY AROUND
THE PFIZER VACCINE, BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, DR. FAUCI, WHO
RECEIVED THE MODERNA OR THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON SHOTS?
WHEN WILL THEY BE ABLE TO START
GETTING BOOSTERS?
>> THEY HAVE NOT BEEN FORGOTTEN,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS THE
DATA ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BOOSTERS IN THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE COMING TO THE FDA I
WOULD IMAGINE IN A COUPLE TO
THREE WEEKS.
THEY WILL EXAMINE IT IN THE SAME
WAY AS THEY DID BEFORE AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WOULD
PROVIDE EQUITY AMONG PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD DIFFERENT PRODUCTS IN
THEIR VACCINATION REGIMEN.
>> THE BRAZILIAN PRESIDENT WHO
IS CURRENTLY IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR THE UNITED NATIONS
GENERAL ASSEMBLY IN NEW YORK
SAYS HE DOESN'T NEED TO GET
VACCINATED BECAUSE HE PREVIOUSLY
HAD THE CORONAVIRUS AND SAYS HIS
IMMUNE SYSTEM IS STRONG ENOUGH.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT
ARGUMENT?
>> WELL, THERE IS SOME TRUTH TO
THAT IN THE FACT THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE VACCINATED -- EXCUSE ME, WHO
HAVE GOTTEN INFECTED AND RECOVER
DO HAVE A DEGREE OF PROTECTION.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW, WOLF, IS
WHAT THE DURATION OF THAT
PROTECTION IS AND WHAT THE RANGE
OF PROTECTION AGAINST VARIANTS
ARE, SO YOU DON'T WANT TO DENY
THAT THERE IS CERTAIN PROTECTION
BY PEOPLE WHO ARE PREVIOUSLY
VACCINATED.
WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT'S REALLY
SPORIN IF YOU VACCINATE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE RECOVERED FROM GETTING
INFECTED, THAT YOU BOOST UP
THEIR LEVEL OF IMMUNITY VERY
HIGH, FAR HIGHER THAN JUST PLAIN
VACCINATION ALONE, SO THAT'S THE
REASON WHY THE CDC STILL
RECOMMENDS THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
RECOVERED FROM NATURAL INFECTION
STILL GO ON AND GET VACCINATED.
>> YEAH.
JUST LIKE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE HAD COVID BUT HE STILL GOT
VACCINATED WHICH IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE U.S. IS ALSO RELAXING
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ON FULLY
VACCINATED INTERNATIONAL AIR
TRAVELERS.
SHOULD WE EXPECT TO SEE
RESTRICTIONS REQUIRING DOMESTIC
AIR TRAVELERS TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED AS WELL?
>> WELL, AS I MENTIONED BEFORE,
WOLF, THAT IS ON THE TABLE FOR
DISCUSSION.
THERE HAS BEEN NO DETERMINATION
ABOUT THAT, BUT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE CONTINUALLY
DISCUSSED, AND I CAN SAY IT'S
STILL ON THE TABLE FOR
CONSIDERATION, BUT IT HASN'T
BEEN DECIDED ABOUT WHAT TO DO
WITH THAT.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID THAT FOR DOMESTIC
FLIGHT